the start date for godzilla and king
kong's event has been confirmed plus
we're gonna go over some details for
halo's last spartan standing mode
if you're a fan of giant lizards and
apes well this story is for you
activision has revealed the call of duty
season 3 road map for both vanguard and
warzone which includes the operation
monarch event centered around godzilla
and king kong for those of you
interested in the lore monarch is the
name of the fictional science company
from 2014's godzilla movie season 3 will
arrive on april 27th packed with new
operators weapons a new battle pass and
more operation monarch however begins on
may 11th while the event is still a ways
away activision teased map changes and
secrets to uncover on the island in
preparation for the arrival of the
hollywood titans season 3 will also add
new multiplayer maps as well as a new
gulag location mayhem will be a small
map available at launch while sphere is
another small size map but coming later
in the season another major addition to
multiplayer is the trophy system
equipment coming to vanguard as a new
field upgrade which will allow players
to help avoid death by vanguard's wealth
of lethal and tactical equipment the
vanguard update will go live on april
26th at 9am pacific 12 p.m eastern and
the war zone update will go live on
april 27th at the same time now let's
switch gears and talk about another
shooter that's preparing for a new
season halo infinite today developer 343
industries provided a rundown of some of
the new and returning modes fans can
expect with the new season this includes
the battle royale like last spartan
standing mode which is all about
fighting for survival 12 players spawn
onto big team battle maps with a
confined loadout and 5 respawns run out
of lives and it's all over the players
can still spectate or quit without being
penalized multiplayer designer zack
boyce said in a blog post that an early
version of live spartan standing did not
include set loadouts which led people to
camp and hide banking their respawns and
power weapons in a gun game style twist
players can upgrade a different weapon
with each kill this should sound pretty
familiar to those who know halo's
escalation slayer last barton standing
ends when one spartan remains alive so
this is definitely a battle royale like
mode even if 343 did not use that
terminology last barton standing will be
available in halo infinite when lone
wolves launches on may 3rd and halo
isn't the only game getting a mode with
battle royale influence rocket league is
adding a new limited time event called
knockout bash on april 27th in which
players will battle it out to be the
last car standing unlike rocket league's
regular soccer modes knockout bash
ditches balls and goals as eight players
must knock each other off of platforms
or into hazards until one player remains
this mode will play out across three
different arenas and players will need
to master new gameplay mechanics such as
blocking and grabbing if they want to
survive the free-for-all action knockout
doesn't have unlimited respawns as
players will be knocked out of the game
once they've been eliminated three times
any player knocked into the safe zone
will have 10 seconds to return to the
arena with that arena shrinking in size
knockout bash will be live from april 27
to may 10th honestly out of everything
we just talked about that knockout bash
mode is what's got me the most excited
but let me know in the comments what
you're most excited to try out you can
follow me on twitter at devante chisholm
and i will see you
tomorrow
[Music]